Розпочинаємо урок математики. 5 клас.
Тема нашого уроку:
«Віднімання десяткових дробів».
Для того, щоб урок пройшов з користю,
приготуйте, будь ласка, зошит та ручку.
Перш ніж почати вивчати нову тему,
повторимо попередній матеріал.
Запишіть у вигляді десяткового дробу.
Увага на екран
Давайте перевіримо ваш результат.
Десятковий дріб має
цілу та дробову частину.
Тому,
три десятих
ми запишемо,
як 0 цілих 3 десятих.
Дві цілих чотири десятих
запишемо, як 2 цілих 4 десятих.
Нагадаю вам,
що у дробовій частині десяткового дробу
повинно стояти стільки цифр,
скільки нулів
у знаменнику звичайного дробу.
В знаменнику, 6 сотих, стоїть два нулі.
Тому ми записуємо
5 цілих 6 сотих.
А тепер пригадаємо,
як ми будемо додавати десяткові дроби.
Увага на екран.
Знайдемо суму чисел
35 цілих 8 десятих та 8 цілих 45 сотих.
Спочатку, запишемо числа у стовпчик
таким чином, щоб кома опинилась під комою.
Далі,
вирівняємо кількість десяткових
знаків у дробовій частині.
Для цього,
в перший дріб, у дробову
частину допишемо в кінці нуль.
Від цього наш дріб не змінився.
Виконаємо додавання.
В результаті,
поставимо кому під комами у доданках.
А тепер перейдемо до вивчення нової теми.
Дивимось на екран.
Знайдемо різницю чисел
9 цілих 568 тисячних
і 3 цілих 12 сотих.
Запишемо ці числа у стовпчик таким чином,
щоб кома опинилась під комою.
Увага на екран.
Вирівняємо кількість знаків
після коми у другому числі.
В кінці допишемо нуль.
Виконаємо віднімання.
8-0=8,
6-2=4,
5-1=4,
9-3=6.
В результаті, поставимо кому під комами.
Отримали 6 цілих 448 тисячних.
Переходимо до наступного етапу роботи.
Розв’яжемо приклади на віднімання.
9 цілих 3 десятих
відняти 3 цілих 2 десятих.
Записали дроби таким чином,
щоб кома опинилась під комою.
Увага на екран.
Починаємо віднімати.
3-2=1,
9-3=6.
Ставимо кому під комами.
Отримали 6 цілих 1 десяту.
Наступний приклад.
22 цілих 95 сотих
відняти 2 цілих 5 сотих.
Знову записали таким чином наші числа,
щоб кома опинилась під комою.
5-5=0,
9-0=9,
2-2=0.
І 2 просто зносимо.
Кому поставили під комами.
Ми отримали результат 20 цілих 90 сотих.
Але ми можемо записати
цей дріб трішки по іншому.
Подивіться на дошку.
20 цілих 9 десятих.
Пам’ятаємо, що нулі в кінці
дробової частини, можемо не писати.
Наступний приклад.
5 цілих 64 сотих
відняти 2 цілих 5 десятих.
Записали числа так,
щоб кома була під комою.
І вирівняли кількість знаків
у дробовій частині у другому числі.
Дописали нуль.
Виконуємо віднімання.
4-0=4,
6-5=1,
5-2=3.
Поставили кому під комою в результаті.
Далі.
33 цілих треба відняти 6 цілих 1 десята.
Дивимось на екран. Давайте пригадаємо.
В числі 33 де стоїть кома?
В даному числі у нас
є тільки ціла частина.
І після цієї частини ставимо кому.
Підписуємо другий дріб.
6 цілих 1 десята.
Поглянули на екран.
Оскільки дробова
частина в числі 33 відсутня,
ми можемо дописати нулі в дробову частину.
Тепер виконуємо віднімання.
Для того, щоб від нуля відняти один,
нам треба зайняти
з попереднього розряду десяток.
1O-1=9.
Оскільки ми від числа 3 вже зайняли 1,
то в нас буде – два мінус шість.
Від двох шість не віднімаємо.
Знову, із старшого розряду
займаємо десяток.
12-6=6.
І замість трьох залишилася двійка.
Отримали 26 цілих 9 десятих.
Ще залишилося розв’язати два приклади.
89 цілих 6 десятих
відняти
4 цілих 111 тисячних.
Дописуємо нулі в перше число.
Виконуємо віднімання.
У шести займаємо десяток і
розписуємо – дев’ять, десять.
Дивимось на екран.
1O-1=9
9-1=8.
Оскільки ми зайняти тут одиничку,
залишилося п’ять.
5-1=4;
9-4=5.
І вісім зносимо.
Отримали 85 цілих 489 тисячних.
І останній приклад.
32 цілих.
Ми вже знаємо, що після цілої частини
можемо поставити кому
і дописати необхідну кількість нулів.
Дописуємо два нулі.
Увага на екран.
Відняти 1 цілу 5 сотих.
Займаємо, розписуємо.
1О-5=5;
9-0=9;
1-1=0.
Три зносимо.
В результаті, отримали 30 цілих 95 сотих.
Дамо рукам відпочити і попрацюємо усно.
Питання до глядачів:
Який із даних десяткових дробів
дорівнює дробу,
записаному на дошці?
Перевіримо ваш результат.
Увага на екран.
Так, цей дріб 0 цілих 73 десятитисячних.
Який із даних десяткових дробів
найбільший?
Перевіряємо?
Згадаємо правило порівняння дробів.
Спочатку порівняємо цілі частини.
Дивимось на екран.
У цих чотирьох дробів
цілі частини однакові.
Переходимо до порівняння дробових частин,
починаючи з найстаршого розряду.
Найстарший розряд – це розряд десяті:
5; 5; 5; 5.
Розряд десяті однаковий
в усіх чотирьох дробах.
Переходимо до розряду сотень:
6; 6; 5; 5.
У подальшому порівнянні беруть участь
тільки перший та другий дріб.
І тепер подивимось на розряд тисячні.
В першому дробі,
в розряді тисячні, стоїть нуль.
А в другому дробі – одиниця.
Тому, другий дріб - найбільший
серед запропонованих дробів.
Розв’яжемо більш складний приклад.
15 цілих 19 сотих
додати 1О цілих 2 десятих,
відняти 4 цілі 6 тисячних.
Даний приклад будемо розв’язувати по діях.
Перша дія.
Знаходимо суму перших двох чисел.
15 цілих 19 сотих додаємо
1O цілих 2 десятих.
Вирівнюємо кількість цифр
в дробовій частині.
9+0=9;
1+2=3;
5+0=5;
1+1=2.
В результаті, нагадую,
кому ставимо під комами,
які стоять у доданках.
Друга дія.
Дія віднімання.
25 цілих 39 сотих
треба відняти 4 цілих 6 тисячних.
Дописуємо нуль в кінці
дробової частини першого дробу.
Для того, щоб від нуля відняти шість,
займаємо десяток.
1O-6=4.
Замість дев’яти тепер стоїть вісім.
3-0=3;
5-4=1.
Два зносимо.
І ми вже знаємо, що
кома ставиться під комою.
В результаті отримали
21 цілу триста 84 тисячних.
Перевіримо наш результат.
Він повністю співпав
з правильною відповіддю.
Давайте розв’яжемо таку задачу.
Треба дізнатися. На скільки сума чисел:
145 цілих двісті 58 тисячних
і 12 цілих 36 сотих,
більша за різницю чисел:
125 цілих 6 десятих
і 13 цілих 56 сотих.
Спочатку знайдемо суму двох чисел.
145 цілих 258 тисячних
додати
12 цілих 36 сотих.
Записали числа так, щоб
кома опинилася під комою.
Дописали нуль у
дробову частину другого числа.
8+0=8;
5+6=11.
Одиницю записали,
запам’ятали.
1+2=3;
3+3=6;
5+2=7;
4+1=5.
Один зносимо.
В результаті, ставимо кому
під комами, які стоять у доданках.
Знайдемо різницю чисел.
125 цілих 6 десятих
віднімемо
13 цілих 56 сотих.
Допишемо нуль в кінець першого числа.
Увага на екран.
1O-6=4;
5-5=0;
5-3=2;
2-1=1.
Один зносимо.
Кому ставимо під комами.
Нам треба дізнатися на скільки сума,
яку ми отримали
більша за різницю.
Для цього ми повинні від
суми відняти отриману різницю.
157 цілих
618 тисячних
відняти
112 цілих 4 сотих.
Дописуємо нуль.
8-0=8;
11-4=7;
5-0=5;
7-2=5;
5-1=4;
1-1=0.
На початку числа нуль не пишемо.
Кому ставимо під комами.
Отримали
45 цілих 578 тисячних.
Саме на стільки наша сума
більше за отриману різницю.
Готові йти далі?
Ще одне завдання.
Нам треба знайти суму чисел:
13 сотих та числа 51 ціла 9 десятих.
Зверніть увагу, що перше число –
це звичайний дріб.
Друге число – це десятковий дріб.
Щоб працювати з цими числами,
нам треба звичайний дріб
перетворити у десятковий дріб.
Я на дошці, одразу запишу
умову таким чином,
щоб перший дріб був представлений
у вигляді десяткового дробу.
0 цілих.
Оскільки 13 сотих не має цілих.
13 сотих
додати
51 цілу 9 десятих.
Виконаємо додавання у стовпчик.
Зверніть увагу,
що ціла частина у другому числі
більша за цілу частину у першому числі.
Тому зручніше першим числом
у стовпчику буде записати друге число.
Адже, від зміни місцями доданків
наша сума не зміниться.
51 ціла 9 десятих
додати 0 цілих 13 сотих.
Дописали нуль.
0+3=3;
9+1=1O.
Нуль пишемо,
одиничку переносимо в наступний розряд.
1+1=2.
П’ять зносимо.
Кому ставимо під комою.
Результат отримали 52 цілі 3 сотих.
Підведемо підсумки цього уроку.
Увага на екран.
Наш урок закінчується.
Лунає дзвоник.
Я вдячна вам за увагу.
Сподіваюся, що урок був корисним.
До наступної зустрічі.